[Musica]
subito dopo la laurea mi sono laureato
in scienze agrarie incominciato
cominciato ad avere una serie di
interrogativi mi sono posto una serie
interrogativi pensando che in effetti
quel percorso di studi mi avesse formato
bene come avrò nomi perché mi aveva dato
tutte quelle nozioni tecniche per poter
produrre appunto del cibo e e quindi
fare è stato un ottimo tecnico in grado
di soddisfare la richiesta della società
la società ci chiede di produrre perché
tutti noi abbiamo bisogno di consumare
noi dipendiamo essenzialmente dal cibo
se non mangiamo non possiamo ovviamente
vivere a un certo punto nel corso del
tempo ho incominciato a pensare ma in
effetti questo percorso mia mi ha dato
soltanto un punto di vista c'è il punto
di vista squisitamente tecnico e diretto
tra virgolette egoistico dell'uomo cioè
mi sentivo a un certo punto come essere
umano distaccato dall'elemento natura
cioè io sarei stato in grado di produrre
del cibo sarei stato in grado di
conoscere le tecniche magari pure
all'avanguardia però in realtà mi sarei
sentito comunque estraneo all'ambiente
naturale
in effetti se ci pensiamo un po tutti ci
preoccupiamo della dell'ambiente a volte
lo vediamo distante da noi
ci estraniamo quasi quindi l'idea era
quella di poter pensare a qualcosa che
potesse come dire riconciliare l'uomo
con l'ambiente e c'è quindi la società
che è imprescindibile dal dall'ambiente
naturale tutti noi non possiamo
prescindere dall'elemento natura e
naturale per cui a un certo punto ho
pensato che dovesse essere forse giusto
ripensare un po a al modello di sviluppo
e vedere un po come l'uomo può ritornare
a essere parte integrante dell'ambiente
e come un sistema produttivo possa in
realtà riconciliare sia l'uomo come
appunto consumatore come colui che in
effetti abbiamo visto anche della
relazione precedente del di massimiliano
capalbo c'è arrivato dal punto di vista
temporale proprio pochi secondi fa
perché era il sistema nostro il nostro
sistema si è formato e la vita sulla
terra è comparsa circa 4 miliardi di
anni fa
noi esistiamo appena da qualche
centinaio di milioni di anni
quindi stiamo parlando di frazioni di
secondo e allora ho pensato che avremmo
dovuto fare qualcosa per riconciliare
questi due aspetti è proprio così che
infatti che noi
l'uomo sostanzialmente si riconosce in
sé questo richiamo della natura cioè
perché di fatto lui è nato come è nato
sulla terra e si andava alla ricerca di
cibo per soddisfare i propri bisogni e
apprezzava appunto questa cosa perché
proprio lui doveva darsi da fare per
raccogliere il cibo e quindi era la sua
la sua unica fonte di salvezza e quindi
diciamo che proprio così inizia questo
percorso quando quando l'uomo diventa
agricoltore e lo fa attraverso come fa a
diventare a capire che poteva produrre
del cibo lo fa attraverso attraverso
l'osservazione cioè fa un enorme
scoperta scopre il seme capisce che le
piante ci riescono a riprodursi e che
quindi se lui riuscì riuscirà a capire
nel meccanismo attraverso appunto la
riproduzione avrà più cibo è proprio
così che in effetti da da 10.000 anni fa
circa si arriva ai tempi d'oggi oggi
guardando quelle immagini e lì quel
grattacielo di che un bosco verticale
che forse a tutti tutti voi avrete
capito che si tratta del grattacielo a
milano famosissimo rappresenta proprio
questa ricerca spasmodica di tornare un
po alla natura c'è il fatto stesso come
se noi avessimo bisogno di ossigeno
ci sentiamo quasi ormai soffocare e
quindi dovremmo chiederci come la
vediamo questa questo ambiente naturale
cioè
come soprattutto c'è che valore richiamo
ad attribuire l'uomo infatti nel tempo
cosa ha fatto o non ha fatto altro che
modificare l'ecosistema naturale a
proprio vantaggio
cioè si è nonostante sia una parte del
sistema naturale e quindi non estraneo
adesso la modificato ovviamente per
trarre maggiori benefici c'è
l'agricoltura quindi sfruttando le
risorse naturali mettendo in atto tutti
i sistemi agricoli ha fatto sì che
questi sistemi diventassero sempre più
semplici e sempre più specializzati
settoriali c'è l'uomo riuscito a
estrarre dalla complessità del sistema
quello che lui interessava in modo
particolare e ha creato ad un sistema
produttivo che ovviamente non ha fatto
altro che danneggiare la biodiversità
dell'ecosistema la biodiversità cioè
quell enorme varietà genetica di esseri
viventi che nel loro insieme
costituiscono appunto come si è detto
anche precedentemente un unico organismo
alla fine interagisce interagiscono
tutti questi sedimenti tradiscono tra
loro per un solo fine quello della
sopravvivenza quello di riuscire ad
adattarsi alle alle a eventi tragici o
anche a modificarsi di alcuni parametri
ambientali e quindi l'uomo che cosa fa
sfrutta enormemente le risorse a proprio
vantaggio ma un costo ambientale enorme
allora io ho pensato che potesse
esistere un modello non l'ho inventato
io
negli ultimi anni si sente molto parlare
della food forest è un sistema pratico
lette nuovo che simula sostanzialmente
quello che avviene nei sistemi naturali
in un bosco c'è l'uomo quando era
raccoglitore non faceva nulla
camminava trovava il proprio cibo
raccoglieva erbe
più parti di piante e frutti è in realtà
è un ecosistema
noi possiamo fare qualcosa possiamo
riprodurlo possiamo tentare di creare un
sistema produttivo che simuli quello che
avviene in una semplice foresta i
principi sono quelli che sono stati
lanciati negli anni passati da premi
coltura permacoltura di morrison e le
tecniche di fuco ago fukuoka
quest'ultimo dice appunto che l'uomo non
dovrebbe fare quasi nulla dovrebbe
soltanto limitarsi ad assecondare la
natura nel nei suoi processi ma non deve
assolutamente incidere in maniera in
maniera pesante cioè con interventi che
possono appunto alterare questo
equilibrio altrimenti ne avremo delle
conseguenze la food forest che
letteralmente è una foresta dice una
festa alimentare cioè una foresta di
cibo si compone di 7 livelli in questo
modello cioè composto da alberi di alto
fusto arbusti un po più bassi cespugli
rampicanti piante erbacee annuali o
anche perenni e tutto questo crea una
relazione che va appunto a trovare un
proprio equilibrio come appunto un
sistema boschivo forestale
la cosa bella è che questo sistema
riesce ad auto mantenersi così come
viene in acqua
la domanda qual è felice perché
realizzarono con forrest una for forest
riesce a raggiungere entrambi e poi
valori cioè praticamente riesce ad
incrementare la biodiversità locale con
il numero di audi di specie viventi la
diversità genetica riduce la co2 la
produzione aumenta la produzione di
ossigeno naturalmente effettua una
importante protezione del suolo contro
l'erosione e anche gli inquinanti riduce
il rischio idrogeologico recuperare e
degradate
è senz'altro un rifugio e fonte di cibo
per animali selvatici e domestici anche
io mi viene da pensare al problema che
si sta vivendo negli ultimi anni il
problema della moria delle api noi
dipendiamo strettamente alleati nella
nostra vita dipende storia dei dati
le api stanno morendo ma muoiono perché
i sistemi produttivi non agricoli e gli
ambienti agricoli non sono più adatti
alla loro sopravvivenza perché sono
ricchi di inquinanti rappresenta
senz'altro quella resilienza che hanno i
sistemi naturali
c'è una food forest un sistema che
produce cibo è che simula in effetti gli
ecosistemi naturali non fa altro che
aumentare la propria resilienza ma anche
un valore sociale voi immaginate di
poter creare una food forest per ogni
comunità urbana in uno spazio magari
poco utilizzato marginale eccetera
noi possiamo creare una food forest
mettendo appunto questo sistema
produttivo con delle essenze che noi
decidiamo di piantumare e senza
ovviamente che tornano cioè che
producono cibo quindi alberi da frutto e
quant'altro e quindi aumenta anche e
soprattutto la consapevolezza nelle
generazioni e generazioni che avendo un
contatto diretto con il sistema
produttivo si riescono ad avere una
maggiore consapevolezza del valore
ambientale come anche aumenta anche la
salute di chi ci va chi chi chi la
frequenta di chi ne fa uso
aumenta il livello culturale dei
cittadini si formano nuove competenze
aggrega la comunità riesce a far
ritornare assieme e aggregare la società
che a volte in questi anni vi vive un po
un po in crisi da la possibilità di
produrre il proprio cibo è una fonte
alimentare e legnose perché produce
molte vice di frutta verdure e non
ultimo il divertimento cioè andare a
passeggiare come facciamo tutti noi
quando abbiamo un po di tempo libero in
un sistema in un bosco a fare una
passeggiata in mezza natura senz'altro
ci fa star bene e ci divertiamo
anche come funziona funziona
sostanzialmente una forte simone così
temo boschivo e lo fa principalmente
attraverso le cose all'incremento la
partita della fertilità del suolo
in pratica si crea un sistema di vita
nel suolo attraverso cui le piante ne
traggono beneficio e del tempo listello
dell'intero sistema raggiunge un
equilibrio una sinergia tra le tra gli
esseri viventi che sono presenti sia i
vegetali che gli animali si crea appunto
una cena un rapporto simbiotico e di
catena alimentare tra le specie nel
tempo appunto l'intero sistema raggiunge
il massimo della propria equilibrio e
quindi non necessita assolutamente
dell'uso di fertilizzante di concimi
chimici
qual è l'idea l'idea è quella di creare
una food forest in ogni città in ogni in
ogni zona in ogni terreno marginale
abbandonato la possibilità di recuperare
aree marginali anche dei terreni
pubblici o privati
chiunque volesse creare una food forest
lo può fare per la può fare nel proprio
giardino nella pur nella prova nella
propria proprio terreno nel proprio orto
con quale obiettivo quello di
raggiungere un servizio di pubblica
utilità ambientale e sociale
la mia esperienza nel 2017 il 2007 o
reali o progettato e realizzato una
piccola foot forest ho piantato 50
specie vegetali diverse tra alberi e
cespugli altre piante pensando proprio
appunto al a quella famosa parolina
biodiversità
ho capito che avrei avrei dovuto mettere
in atto quello che mi mancavano cioè un
sistema che potesse produrre del cibo e
anche contribuire alla salvaguardia
dell'ambiente a creare un ecosistema più
naturale possibile
e allo stesso tempo darmi la possibilità
di consumare di avere del cibo e in
effetti optato come si può vedere qui
per diverse essenze un gelo una cava
americana un pesco un limone un
melograno un ulivo impero pino argentato
in questa foto si può vedere appunto
un piccolo a una piccola parte come
stanno come possono convivere la e stare
in sinergia le piante tutte insieme e
quindi raggiungere un maggiore
equilibrio è una maggiore delle
silienzio pino argentato un banano una
cicas un mandarino un euforbia che una
pianta tipica della nostra costa
l'ambiente mediterraneo ho creato anche
qualche nido per gli uccelli
ecco in questo terreno in questo in
questa poule forest dopo qualche anno
sono ricomparsi gli uccelli
così come sono ricomparsi le api e molti
insetti varie siepi ecco da due anni
comincia ad avere qualche frutto in
frutta e scienza di banano di ciliegio i
duroni il pero il mandarino cinese le
fragoline di eco il forno food forest
che appunto come dicevo si sviluppa su
sette livelli prevede appunto anche
specie rampicanti o striscianti così
come avviene in natura
ti assicuro che queste fra altre che
vedete a destra e le fragoline di bosco
sono diventati invadenti loro rispetto
alle piante infestanti è una cosa che mi
ha sorpreso perché io non credevo
potesse essere così non me l'avevano
detto alla facoltà di agraria che
potesse succedere questo al che a un
certo punto ho dovuto controllare le
fragole che stavano invadendo le altre
cose
ecco le mie figlie sanno molto bene
quanto sono buone quelle fragole e anche
quelle fragoline ecco un sorbo domestico
un corbezzolo tutti per i cosiddetti
minori che abbiamo quasi dimenticato
tutto questo ecco unesco lo un cedro una
pianta di canfora 15 un pulcino biloba
una pianta fossile è un pompelmo un
rosmarino la pianta di rosmarino e di là
guardate un po ecco cosa vedo quando
vado nella food forest vedo quello che
in un sistema agricolo non si trova più
insetti pronubi che vanno ad impallinare
i fiori e vanno a raccogliere in lettere
e il polline
ecco perché la mia foto e sting comincia
a funzionare dopo dieci anni
perché hanno cominciato a trovare il
proprio equilibrio non ho mai fatto uso
di pesticidi un castagno un no c'è una
paulonia e una crisi ha una media una
palma americana una fiore di prassi
flora o il fico d'india un frutto della
passiflora e l'origano raccolto sulle
nostre montagne
va benissimo ha trovato il suo ambiente
ideale
però è tutto quello che c'è il merito di
tutto questo e grazie a questa parolina
qui a questi a questi signorini qui
questi questi organismi che si chiamano
dei compositori che sono appunto i
funghi e i vari lombrichi e di vari
insetti terricoli questi questi questi
insetti e queste queste entità viventi
questi microrganismi fanno sì che il
suolo sia ricco e sia fertile perché
tutto parte da lì così come aveva detto
nell'intervento precedente capalbo sotto
terra e tutto ciò che avviene in maniera
veramente esponenziale
poi si riflette al di sopra della terra
quindi un suolo ricco fertile pieno di
microrganismi è in equilibrio fa sì che
tutti gli esseri viventi che stanno al
di sopra e che si nutrono di esso stiano
in equilibrio
ecco questa è la mia mano potete vedere
quello il suolo lì è veramente ricco di
sostanza organica dopo dieci anni ha
trovato la sua condizione naturale ecco
infine non poteva che esserci la casetta
dei sogni la casetta sull'albero quelle
un eretini acri st galli che io ho
modificato opportunamente in dieci anni
per poterci costruire sopra una casetta
le mie figlie sono felicissime e quindi
auguro a voi tutti una buona fetta
[Applauso]